protesters are back on the streets of
mandalay
less than 24 hours after the security
services shot two dead
and injured many more occupying an
important intersection in the city
the message is clear they will not back
down
footage that has emerged overnight
suggests this was a well-planned and
sustained crackdown
not a temporary lapse in discipline
buildings showing the scars of live
rounds
that were liberally used
the soldiers beat and shot my husband
and others he was standing on the side
and watching the protests but the
soldiers took him away
and while the police took the lead it
appears it was the military
that were in charge soldiers from the
33rd light infantry are said to be in
command
a division known for its violent
crackdowns on ethnic
unrest in myanmar's largest city yangon
the bloodshed in mandalay appeared to
have hardened the resolve
of those protesting against the coup
people died yesterday we protested
peacefully but people had to die
the junta wants to stop us from coming
out onto the streets so they strongly
respond to us
we the people won't accept their unfair
oppression and we will continue to fight
and calls for the international
community to intervene
the numbers of people increase today and
we will not stop
we will continue to walk to our goal
democracy
we want international countries to take
more severe action than effective
sanctions
in the capital nepad a huge funeral
cortege for the first fatality in these
protests
a 20 year old student who died on friday
she's now become a symbol for the
protesters for the sacrifice she made
and the one they may face themselves
tony chang al jazeera